A
HUMAN TRAGEDY UNFOLDING RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT FIRST, AS CALIFORNIA GOES,
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHERE
AMERICA IS HEADED IF WE DON'T
TURN THE TIDE AGAINST BIDEN'S
SOCIALIST REGIME, LOOK NO
FURTHER THAN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOW, I BROUGHT THE SHOW HERE
BECAUSE AMERICANS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE WE ARE HEADED
WITH THE DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE.
FOR BETTER OR WORSE, THE
GOLDEN STATE HAS ALWAYS LED THE
WAY CULTURALLY, POLITICALLY, AND
YES, MORALLY.
THE AMERICAN DREAM IN MANY WAYS,
IT BEGAN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT WASN'T JUST THE LAND OF
SUNSHINE, SURFING USA, AND
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE.
BUT FROM THE GOLD RUSH TO THE
TECH BOOM, IT WAS A PLACE THAT
EPITOMIZED AMERICA'S POTENTIAL
AND LIMITLESS OPPORTUNITIES.
BUT AFTER A DECADE OF DEMOCRATS
DOMINATING EVERY BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT HERE, IT'S ALL
UNRAVELING.
TODAY'S CALIFORNIA CONSISTS OF A
TINY SLIVER OF SUPER WEALTHY
PEOPLE, A GROWING UNDERCLASS,
AND A RAPIDLY-SHRINKING MIDDLE
CLASS THAT IS SET UP AND RUNNING
FOR THE EXITS.
FOR ALL OF THEIR CLAIMS OF BEING
PROGRESSIVE, CALIFORNIA THOUGH
IS AMONG THE MOST REGRESSIVE
STATES IN THE COUNTRY.
OVER THE PAST DECADE, 80% OF THE
STATE'S JOBS HAVE PAID UNDER
MEDIAN WAGE, HALF OF WHICH ARE
PAID LESS THAN $40,000, AND MOST
ARE IN POORLY PAID PERSONAL
SERVICES OR HOSPITALITY JOBS.
EVEN AT SOME OF THE STATE'S MOST
PRESTIGIOUS COMPANIES LIKE
GOOGLE, MANY LOWER AND EVEN
MID-LEVEL WORKERS LIVED IN
MOBILE HOME PARKS.
IF OTHERS SLEEP IN THEIR CARS.
AND THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE NOW LIVE ON THE STREETS.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE YOU INSIDE
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS SWAMPING
THE CITY LATER ON IN THE SHOW.
NOW IT'S SO BAD THAT EVEN
DEMOCRAT VOTERS MAY FINALLY BE
WAKING UP.
>> LET ME WORK, LET ME PAY MY
TAXES BUT PROVIDE ME WITH SAFETY
AND NOT BE ACCOSTED BY TWO
HOMELESS PEOPLE WITHIN A MATTER
OF 15 MINUTES.
>> IS THIS GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
FAULT?
>> I MEAN, TECHNICALLY...
HOW COULD I EVEN ANSWER THAT?
HE'S THE LEADER.
EVERYTHING STARTS FROM THE TOP
AND IT GOES DOWN.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
VERY WORRIED BECAUSE THEY ARE
DEFINED THE POLICE CRUSADE HAS
LED TO SKYROCKETING CRIME.
THOSE WOMEN ARE FEELING IT.
IN L.A., MURDERS ARE UP NEARLY
24%, SHOOTINGS ARE UP ALMOST
38%.
IN SAN FRANCISCO, WHERE WE WERE
JUST EARLIER THIS WEEK,
SHOOTINGS ARE UP 105% DURING THE
FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR ALONE.
SO POLICE ARE UNDERSTAFFED AND
OUTGUNNED AND AT THE SAME TIME,
WE LEFT LEFT WING D.A.s TO RUN
AMOK, PEOPLE LIKE CHESTER
BOOTING IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND GEORGE GASCON HERE IN L.A.,
TOTAL TRAVESTY.
OF THEY ARE MORE FOCUSED ON
LETTING THE CRIMINALS WALK FREE
THAN SEEING THEM LOCKED UP AND
OFF THE STREETS.
>> IF PEOPLE WERE ARRESTING ON
PROBATION, ON THE ELECTRONIC
ANKLE MONITORING AND IT STILL
DOESN'T DETER THEM FROM GOING
OUT AND COMMITTING THESE CRIMES,
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WON'T DO ANYTHING.
>> SO IT'S A REVOLVING DOOR OF
CRIMINALITY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
OFTENTIMES THESE PEOPLE, IF THEY
ARE ARRESTED, WILL BE BACK OUT
OF JAIL BEFORE THE POLICE
OFFICERS ARE DONE WRITING THE
POLICE REPORT.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT JUST A
CRIME OF THE HOMELESSNESS
THOUGH.
DEMOCRAT POLICIES FROM LOCKDOWNS
TO HIGH TAXES UPON HER SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND
ENTREPRENEURS AS WELL.
AND WHEN GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
IS ASKED TO EXPLAIN WHY SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING FOR THE RED
STATES, HE JUST GETS DISMISSIVE
AND DEFENSIVE.
>> WE HAD BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES
IN FLORIDA AND TEXAS AND BETTER
ECONOMIC OUTCOMES.
I'M PROUD OF THE FACT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A HOUSING POLICY
AND HOMELESS POLICY FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN DECADES.
EVERYBODY OUTSIDE THE STATE IS
[BLEEP] ABOUT THE STATE BECAUSE
OF OUR SUCCESS.
>> Laura: GO BACK TO PLUMP
JACK WINERY, MY FRIEND.
BY THE WAY -- AND THEY ALSO
LITERALLY CAN'T KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON OR WATER RUNNING HERE.
UNDER NEWSOME, THE STATE SAW ITS
FIRST ROLLING BLACKOUTS SINCE
2001 THANKS IN PART TO INSANE
LEFT-WING CLIMATE POLICIES,
FACES A POTENTIAL SUPPLY FOR
SHORTFALL OF ABOUT 2.6 MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS, FORCING GRUESOME
NEWSOM TO ALLOW INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES TO RUN ON DIESEL
GENERATORS, THAT'S GREAT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
UP SO MUCH FOR GOING GREEN.
THINGS ARE SO DESPERATE HERE
THAT NEWSOM IS NOW PAYING PEOPLE
TO CUT DOWN ON ENERGY USE, I KID
YOU NOT.
BUT IT'S NOT BILLIONAIRES LIKE
OPRAH WINFREY UP IN MONTECITO OR
MARK ZUCKERBERG WHO GET HIT WITH
THE DEMOCRATS GROSS KILLING
TAXES, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
THAT, THEY ARE SO RICH.
IT'S THE MIDDLE CLASS THAT GETS
HIT.
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY AND CLIMATE
RIGS ARE SO CRIPPLING TO WORKING
FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY MINORITIES,
THEY'VE ACTUALLY BEEN DUBBED THE
GREEN JIM CROW.
AND LARRY ELDER, THE LEADING
REPUBLICAN IN THE SEPTEMBER 14TH
RECALL EFFORT AIMS TO TURN ALL
OF THIS AROUND.
>> WHAT YOUR FIRST THING YOU'RE
GOING TO DO?
>> TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
ANY STATEWIDE MANDATES FOR MASK
WEARING UPPER VACCINE FOR STATE
WORKERS, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
REPEALED.
I'M GOING TO DECLARE PUBLIC
EMERGENCY AND HOMELESSNESS, I'M
GOING TO DECLARE A PUBLIC
EMERGENCY ON WATER.
>> Laura: MORE FROM A
CANDIDATE FROM HIS OLD
NEIGHBORHOOD IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS.
WHAT WE ARE REVEALING TO HER
TONIGHT IS CAUTIONARY TALE.
THE MEDIA IS SHOWING FOR NEWSOM
AND THE TEACHERS UNIONS.
IF THAT'S HAPPENING, BUT NOT OF
THAT CAN FACT, THE TRUTH, THE
CALIFORNIA IS DYING A SLOW AND
PAINFUL DEATH.
BUT A POLITICAL BACKLASH IS
STILL BREWING.
AT THE PEOPLE STILL HAVE THE
POWER TO TURN THE TIDE.
NOW IS THE TIME TO THROW THE
LEFTIST BOMBS OUT AND CALIFORNIA
CAN LEAD THE NATION ONCE AGAIN
BY SENDING A POWERFUL MESSAGE
TO THE POLITICAL ESTABLISH